bonjour à tous mercredi dernier robert
badinter l'ancien garde des sceaux a été
auditionné par la commission spéciale
sur la lutte contre le système
prostitutionnel
objectif de cette commission spéciale
examinée au fond la proposition de loi
socialiste qui vise à renforcer la lutte
contre le système prostitutionnel et le
proxénétisme à mieux protéger les
victimes et à établir un véritable
parcours de sortie de la prostitution ce
texte s'est fait avant tout connaître
également car elle pénalise les clients
de prostituées
mercredi l'ancien garde des sceaux a
exprimé tout son scepticisme vis-à-vis
de ce texte il a également c'est un
véritable inventaire des formes de
prostitution des nouvelles formes de
prostitution occasionnelle par exemple
pour boucler les fins de mois ou bien
encore pour s'offrir des produits de
luxe des phénomènes que l'ancien garde
des sceaux a qualifié de mâle moderne
tout de suite donc retour à cette
audition qui s'est tenue mercredi au
sénat nous avons le plaisir et l'honneur
aujourd'hui de recevoir monsieur
badinter ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel ancien garde des sceaux
et ancien collègue au sénat je dois dire
que pendant tout le temps où j'ai siégé
quand je suis arrivé en 2001 j'ai
toujours beaucoup apprécié les
interventions ce soit en groupe point
séance monsieur badinter et donc notre
travail se poursuivent nous aurons
encore des auditions publiques la
semaine prochaine nous avons des
auditions programmées au moins jusqu'au
28 mai et peut-être des auditions mois
de juin quand nous pourrons auditionner
les ministres concernés donc masson plus
tarder je vais à moins que notre
reporter michel meunier des questions
préalables à poser je vais laisser la
parole monsieur badinter et puis
l'employer nous pourrons poser des
questions et ouvrir la discussion nous
avons souhaité vous auditionné parce que
moi je vais souffrir d'un certain nombre
de vos interventions en séance notamment
lorsqu'on a débattu donc de la loi
sécurité publique en 2003 jean remonte
intime un petit peu et donc de fait de
la compétence qui est la vôtre nous
souhaitions avoir votre analyse de cette
proposition de loi une proposition de
loi et non pas un projet doit qu elle
nous vient de l'assemblée nationale donc
je réitère mes propos le sénat a déjà
beaucoup travaillé sur le thème puisque
ça fait à peu près presque deux ans que
nous travaillons sur ce thème d'abord
par une mission d'information avec
madame chantal jouanno sur la situation
sanitaire et sociale les personnes
prostituées et depuis que le texte nous
est arrivé sur le texte qui nous est
parvenu de l'assemblée nationale donc
sans plus attendre je vais vous laisser
la parole et puis nous ouvrirons la
discussion avec les collègues et qui ne
manqueront pas encore pour certains de
nous rejoindre merci beaucoup de votre
présence
merci monsieur le président je salue
j'aime le reporter
mais je le dis jamais que chers
collègues mais
je dirais mais l'ambitieux
chacun sachant que ce sont des chers
collègues nous donne d'ailleurs une
impression étrange
revenir ici cet endroit mais cette
tribune
serait un côté sénateur à vie il n'est
pas désagréable regard des grands
prédécesseurs républicains
aujourd'hui l'école l'exit alia mais qui
n'est qu'une illusion et pour un temps
bref
la question
sur laquelle elle fait l'honneur de me
demander de venir est une question et
qui chacun le sait tout à fait
importante très complexe mais que je
n'aborderai pas du point de vue
philosophique y ait un débat je crains
c'est sûr prostitution le régime
les rapports entre la prostitution et
femmes des hommes non dans ce domaine là
je n'ai pas besoin d'intervenir je dis
simplement et très clairement dès le
départ mes positions sont exactement le
talent
bien par celle d'elisabeth
qui par définition a raison et d'ange
épouse ça va de soi les convictions ce
qui me permet d'ailleurs de marquer que
nul
ne saurait m'accuser de n'être pas
féministe parce que si je n'étais pas
féministe je n'aurai pas le privilège de
célébrer bientôt notre 50e anniversaire
de mariage elle n'aurait pas supporté ce
brevet auto décernés je vous dirais que
en effet
les observations s'inscriront dans un
autre ordre c'est le domaine législatif
eu et toute ma vie cette passion
particulière mais pas exclusive des lois
des lois bien fait et des lois qui
exprime très exactement la fois les
motifs pour lesquels ces lois sont
adoptées et qui s'inscrivent dans un
disney ensemble un système de principes
qui sont définies on le sait en europe
occidentale et en europe maintenant plus
généralement par la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme interprétant la
convention de sauvegarde
j'aurais aussi l'occasion évidemment de
comparer la loi à certaines des
exigences de notre droit pénal et ses
principes fondamentaux alors d'abord une
observation
il faut bien marquer ce dont on se rend
pas assez content que le débat très vif
des années 80 même 70 déjà aux états
unis je me suis alors là les premiers
échos
à partir de la théorie des genres et des
visions des féministes radicales
américaine à los angeles j'ai entendu
déjà des assertions qui ont conduit aux
propositions de loi que nous avons
aujourd'hui
phénomène prostitution qui est je le dis
très clairement à mes yeux un mal social
social permanent constant mais qui est
toujours un mal social
la prostitution
changement on peut pas parler de la
prostitution comme le faisait justement
illustrissime sénateur à vie hugo dans
chacun sait que à la fois il est créé
les malheurs de fantine n'était pas tout
à fait insensible au charme de ces dames
non ça n'est plus la même chose à nous
mêmes plus celle qui sévit c'est dans ma
lointaine jeunesse n'est plus du tout ça
aujourd'hui le phénomène de la
prostitution
revêt un aspect beaucoup plus complexe
et divers que dans les années 70 80
d'abord c'est une
prostitution
qu'un caractère international et
migratoire considérable
je relevais dans les documents qui sont
annexés que on estime aujourd'hui à 80 %
la part des étrangers est étrangère dans
la prostitution et ce qui n'est pas le
cas dans les années 70 ou 80
je marque aussi que la prostitution
phénomène mal perçue est aujourd'hui
bisexuel le nombre de prostitués hommes
ne cessent de croître au regard des
effectifs de toute la procédure et on
les évalue selon les sources policières
aujourd'hui à un peu plus de 18 10 yeux
que la rue mais de l'ordre de 10 et à 20
%
c'est aussi et ça c'est plus moderne
encore c'est aussi une prostitution et
qui a un caractère
d'intermittence
d'intermittence parce que la
prostitution occasionnelle
la prostitution pendant une période où
un certain moment est une des
caractéristiques
du de ce mal moderne
pan des raisons qui sont multiples
insultes période de grandes difficultés
économiques
insuffisance de ressources ou bien
pour certaines ou certains
le goût de pouvoir s'offrir tels
vêtements tels vacant sera bref des
plaisirs dispendieux ou venez re que
leur situation ne leur permet pas
d'avoir ça entraîne des phénomènes des
périodes de prostitution occasionnelle
et cette prostitution occasionnelle
parce que de circonstance dont
d'ailleurs les prostituées sorte de cela
est une des marques de l'époque et c'est
lié à un autre phénomène qui alors lui
on le sait exerce ses conséquences sur
jeudi à toute notre société actuelle
c'est le phénomène numérique
l'informatisation il est bien évident
que aujourd'hui
le racolage vont employer le terme
convenable
fait par les prostitué e
s ou es s peu importe s'effectue pour
une grande part sur la toile il y à là
avec l'exhibition
indications codé de tarifs et ces
précisions sur les spécialités un
phénomène qui n'existaient pas
bien que parait-il ou palais royal jadis
jadis c'est à dire au début du 19e
siècle il y avait un guide des dames
avec leurs spécialités et les tarifs en
napoléon d'or mais ceci fait partie d'un
très lointain passé ce qui au contraire
est la dominante et qu'il faut conserver
l'esprit c'est que l'offre
prostitutionnel elle utilise
principalement la toile les réseaux et
que l'utilisation ensuite pour la mise
en oeuvre de l'accord intervenu ainsi
utilise beaucoup le téléphone mobile
donc on est en présence d'un phénomène
mauvais encore une fois un mal social
mais qui épouse
le temps et que par conséquent il faut
prendre dans sa réalité et sa diversité
alors je vais être très clair si aucune
raison que je ne dise pas ma pensée
elle ma pensée basée sur des
considérations pour beaucoup juridique
le texte le texte de propositions et qui
a été adopté par l'assemblée nationale
et donc je donne le titre qui m'a laissé
perplexe renforçant la lutte contre le
système prostitutionnel
je ne sais pas très bien ce qui est un
système prostitutionnel bout de systèmes
dissimule un ensemble de forces
mauvaises qui quelque part se camoufler
dans ce n'est pas exactement ce qu'elles
sont mais qu'ils sont menaçantes voir
l'utilisation politique qu'on fait de
système
aujourd'hui quand on vise le singulier
cancel comme on dit
la leader d'un parti d'extrême droite le
système ump s voilà et bien c'est mieux
sans parler du système franc maçon à
l'époque biologie moi je pense que quand
on aborde le cas sérieux du droit il
faut éviter parler de système contre
lequel on va lutter
map mon propos est clair c'est pas un
bon instrument législatif il pour dire
encore plus
les choses c'est un mauvaise loi qu'on
vous propose alors 7 ça ne veut rien
rien là je tiens à le souligner ça
n'enlève rien aux excellentes intentions
aux intentions qui ont présidé à la
boration de ce témoin je comprends très
bien les réactions des auteurs de ce
texte désir de lutter mais la voie
choisie les techniques jeu est joli et
l'incertitude profonde sur leur validité
tout cela m'amène à vous dire je
considère que ce n'est pas un bon texte
et poussa essentiellement pour trois
raisons la première parce que cette loi
si elle est votée est voué à
l'inefficacité au regard de la cible
qu'elle prétend atteindre à
l'inefficacité
et parce que cette loi si elle est mise
en oeuvre elle entraînera des
conséquences
sociales et personnelles injuste de
céret sera à la fois inefficace elle ne
sera pas juste et puis alors là
c'est du reste ce qui rend compte de la
parole c'est une loi qui n'est pas
conforme aux principes du droit européen
et est toujours sur ce point je me garde
de formuler un diagnostic si éclatant a
causé fonction j'ai eu l'honneur de
remplir suis pas absolument sûr qu'elle
soit conforme à tous les principes
constitutionnels mais je n'en dirai pas
plus je ne peux pas en dire plus il
indiquera s'appelant pourquoi elle n'est
pas conforme aux principes fondamentaux
de notre droit d'envoyer contrariétés au
droit européen dans ses principes de la
convention et contrariétés aux principes
de notre droit pénal alors avant
d'analyser ces trois points
je rappelle qu'elle a une singularité
cette loi
cette loi les directement la projection
l'enfant pourrait-on dire d'un texte de
loi
qui a été adopté
en suède on le sait c'est ce qu'on
appelle le modèle suez loi de
pénalisation des clients qui a été
ensuite adopté en or vaseuses côté
l'islande parce que l'islande je le sais
existe mais enfin c'est un pays dont on
ne peut pas dans un grand état comme le
nôtre tirer quelques exemples que ce
soit alors
s'agissant loi suédoise
je vous indiquerai que
selon ses promoteurs hills est ici je
cite pour ne pas donner le sentiment le
moins du monde une sorte de partialité
et l'attaquent trois phrases que je vais
lire sont extraits d'un rapport
fait au sénat belge
justement à propos de ses problèmes et
rapport belge que je vous déposerait
indique sont les promotrices de la loi
suédoise la prostitution est une forme
de violence masculine contre les femmes
sur la prostitution homosexuelle rats
contre les femmes deuxièmement il est
physiquement et psychologiquement
dommageable de vendre du sexe mais
vendre votre lit même pas ce que c'est
c'est de la communication ça c'est pas
du droit on ne vend pas son corps beau
temps heureusement que l'esclavagé
disparu on le loue pas non plus la
prostitution quand on regarde la
diffusion des finitions donné par la
cour de cassation cette rémunération 20
relations sexuelles rémunérées ou si on
préfère ça se trouve dans d'autres
droits ce soit aussi dans quelques
décisions c'est rendre des services
sexuels contre rémunération
avec incitations publiques
éventuellement mais c'est pas le coeur
la patience et vend des services sexuels
pour quelqu'un qui le fait régulièrement
contre rémunération alors la troisième
est le coeur de la chose s'est il n'y a
aucune femme c'est toujours les pharaons
par jamais ici des homosexuels qui
prostitue volontairement
qui se prostituent volontairement elles
sont nécessairement contrainte par des
proxénètes souvent mafieux c'est moi qui
ai le rajoute et les prostituées de
leurs proches au chef cela n'existe pas
je suis pas sûr quand on regarde la
toile qu'on puisse accepter cette
proposition mais ce que je veux marquer
un ventre et les discussions c'est que
les résultats de cette loi qui remonte à
99 qui a été changé en 2009 si j'ai
bonne mémoire
d'ailleurs les peines ont été aggravées
la loi les résultats sont contestés
c'est à dire que en suède on sonore
grandement d'avoir passé cette loi c'est
bien efficace etc les milieux logiciel
là dessus sont tout-à-fait unanime cette
fois elle nous satisfait
quant au delà des milieux officiels
politiques parlementaires
vous interrogez les choses apparaissent
plus nuancés
plus nuancé et je marque à cet égard il
y a eu de nombreuses enquêtes
internationales
sur les résultats de la pénalisation des
seuls clients en suède et que vraiment
ces enquêtes internationales sont loin
de corroborer ce que l'on nous dit sur
les résultats triomphante de la loi
suédoise mais loin et je rapporte toute
une série que je vous laisserai à cet
égard d'études et de commentaires
généralement universitaire par des
auteurs généralement femmes peu suspect
à cet égard
de rallier des thèses machiste je prends
une jeffrey rapide analyse
par les professeurs suzanne de dieppe et
traoré thèse qui est une suédois c'est
le grand congrès qui a eu en 2011 sur la
décriminalisation de la prostitution au
delà les expériences pratique et les
défis et leur conclusion est très
intéressante pour nous le rapport
conclut que notre position en ce qui
concerne la politique en matière de
prostitution et qu'elle est fondée sur
la connaissance et l'expérience
plutôt que sur la morale ou l'idéologie
radicale féministes nous croyons
également que lorsque les politiques
sont élaborés les acteurs au coeur de
cette politique c'est à dire ici les
prostituées elles mêmes eux mêmes
doivent être consultés et respecter ne
pas être traité en mineur on parle pour
vous de ce que vous souffrez etc non
c'est d'abord d'abord celles et ceux qui
sont ainsi directement impliqués mis en
cause et victimes selon la ce qui nous
est dit et elle rapport ajoute à notre
avis cela n'a pas été le cas en ce qui
concerne le modèle suédois vous verrez
une étude du professeur anglais de la
professeur anglais jail et oui sur les
impacts de la criminalisation suédoise
de l'achat de services sexuels
grand entretien avec la professeur hand
made et magnus sale gueule prostitution
ceux qui en france prom la pénalisation
des clients ont ils conscience que la
suède en fait un bilan mitigé ça c'est
sur un site atlantico vous avez une très
longue étude de madame valeria costa
côté ski il aurait fallu réfléchir à
deux fois avant de faire de la
prostitution à la suédoise un modèle
d'un article des 100 récensés décembre
2013 et également d'un professeur à
l'université
prostitution stockholm où le client la
ville où le client est invisible alors
beaucoup plus intéressante encore que
ces avis ou
à étude faite sur les résultats il ya il
y a deux attitudes parlementaire
pour nous significatif et se sont
penchés sur la question à la fois sauf
question statut des prostituées et la
question de l'expérience ou plutôt de la
loi sur la première
c'est ce que j'ai évoqué la proposition
loi qui est pendante j'ai cité devant le
sénat belge évoqué ce qu'était la les
principes de la loi suédoise je le dis
tout de suite ce rapport belge en face
c'est travail fait au sénat belge est
extrêmement critique à l'égard de la
législation suédoise au vu de ces
résultats mais y'a plus significatif
pour moi en termes politiques c'est que
si la norvège j'ai été en norvège pas
pour ça du tout mais j'ai été en norvège
j'ai eu l'occasion il peut de temps et
dernière de parler à des responsables
j'ai doigt un pardon norvégien
ils vous disaient
une sorte d' incertitude la prostitution
ils ont pris le modèle suédois elle est
simplement devenu clandestine elle s'est
simplement exporter en paca suède mais
vers quoi hors des eaux territoriales et
qui en a bénéficié
parce que dans ce domaine les mafias
sont toujours à la pointe du progrès les
des bateaux russes et qui vont large des
eaux territoriales très importante en
norvège et qui la
transforme disons le très simplement au
bordel flottant ils ont une forte
clientèle extrêmement déplaisant et donc
les norvégiens s'interroge mais le plus
important c'est l'attitude des danois
pourquoi vous appartiennent la même
gignac
sensibilité
communauté de valeurs et eux étaient
s'interroge à la limite peut-être que
devrait de peut-être et il existe ce que
j'ai découvert au parlement danois
l'institution intéressant qui est le
conseil de législation pénale qui est
composé de personnalités
bipartisane ou non partisane notamment
des universitaires des experts et qui
suit de près les résultats
des législations adoptées qui suit aussi
de près les expériences étrangères de
façon à pouvoir faire des suggestions au
parlement tel organe indépendant
purement consultatif mais qui fait ainsi
ce travail d'expertisé constant pour
améliorer les lois danois sont chacun le
sait très pragmatique très commission
mixte paritaire mais très pragmatique
alors ils ont étudié de très près ce qui
se passait en loques suède et en norvège
encore une fois c'est une grande
communauté de valeurs ces pays nordiques
ils font prix dans le domaine carcéral
et je me disais oh moi même que si on
veut adopter des modèles suédois je
préférerais qu'on commence par adopter
le modèle suédois en matière carcéral
pour la revisiter
véritable ont intérêt à les inspirer
sans délai de ce modèle carcérale mais
pour en revenir à ça le conseil après
ces enquêtes donc ces trois institutions
indépendantes a conclu que
l'interdiction d'achat des services
sexuels n'a pas de conséquence positive
sensible en revanche cette interdiction
pourrait avoir des conséquences
négatives
pour un certain nombre de prostituées
qui souffrirait de conditions
économiques dégradées et d'une
stigmatisation
renforcer et en conséquence le conseil
n'a pas recommandé l'interdiction
d'achat de services sexuels et vous
voyez donc que la 2013 tout récemment le
danemark a repoussé le modèle suédois
alors je marque ce soit pour dire que
ainsi le modèle présente tous les
avantages et dont on chante parfois
lyriquement les louanges il suscite plus
d'incertitudes d'interrogations et
parfois de critiques
que
d'inclination à l'adopter mais si je dis
cela ça ne saurait suffire il faut aller
plus loin pourquoi est-ce que je pense
profondément
que face aux mâles de la prostitution la
loi
proposée sera inefficace
et bien pour une raison simple elle se
trompe de cible
je le répète elle se trompe de cible
quelle est aujourd'hui j'ai évoqué les
techniques qu'ils disaient quel est le
mal mais alors propres très supérieur à
ce qui était le cas en période
antérieure aujourd'hui le mal profond
dans le domaine de la prostitution c'est
le traite le trafic organisé honteux
ignobles et extraordinairement lucratif
des êtres humains auxquels se livrent
les mafias c'est véritablement un fléau
un fléau gbagbo assez sévère pour ça un
fléau que cette traite des êtres humains
et c'est un fléau ce mal là qui
aujourd'hui hélas est en augmentation
dans l'ensemble européen là là des
organisations mafieuses nous c'est bien
de cela dont il faut parler elle elle
s'opère aujourd'hui je dirais que le
trafic fret a presque changé dax s'est
encore sud nord mais c'est à l'intérieur
de l'europe
massivement est ouest est très
directement
les éléments actuels en ukraine
ne sont pas de nature à ralentir ce
courant n'a pas besoin d'insister là
dessus ni à ralentir l'activité des
mafias très organisés qui sévissent dans
cette partie de l'europe comme on parle
de mafia albanaise et pour lequel
le prg est la traite les femmes disant
aussi surtout les très jeunes est un des
domaines les plus fructueux d'une
activité criminelle ignoble alors je dis
franchement c'est moi l'aspect des
choses qui me met hors de moi ce trafic
a met hors de moi parce que
ça signifie sous couleur de promesses
d'établissement de l'occident top model
et sert à venir des filles aussi des
garçons mais surtout les filles aient
opté elle là on les tient et on les
tient d'autant plus ignoblement qu'on
n'a même pas besoin contrairement à la
tradition est ce qu on évoque toujours
sur les menaces les violences exercées
sur jeune femme a le même on les tient
pourquoi parce que el sol on l'a fait
venir en lui a assuré la venue en europe
occidentale y compris chez nous a pas
besoin pas besoin d'exercer sur elle les
pressions directes des violences comme
faisaient les barbots jay disent non ça
c'est fini on se borne à lui faire
remarquer qu' on sait où habitent ses
parents on connaît toute la famille et
que par conséquent si elle ne se
comporte pas comme eux lice il
nécessaire ce seront les membres de la
famille qui en subiront les conséquences
hier qu on est au dernier degré au
dernier degré de la criminalité la plus
odieuse c'est ça c'est ça en priorité la
sienne quand
le privilège de vrais la législation
quand en particulier je préside les
travaux du nouveau code pénal ça
longtemps j'avais renforcée déjà à
l'époque
les textes et les pénalités contre ces
trafics d'êtres humains joueurs encore
une fois c'est une des formes les plus
ignobles de la criminalité contemporaine
et maintenant mon jeu le plaisir des
fans dit franchement depuis 7-8 en
oeuvre
toute l'union européenne pour arriver à
rallier un accord ce qui est une
institution nécessaire à quoi moi c'est
l'autre importance que la pénalisation
des clients qui est la création d'un
parquet européen
parce que quand vous avez des réseaux
qui sont eux d'essence
transnationales ça se passe depuis en
effet graines de la vie c'est traverse
ensuite à mandeure le nord vers l'un ça
redescend vers l'europe occidentale
quand vous avez cela il faut une unité
de poursuites il faut un parquet
européen on va avoir des juges européens
vont juger ça mais vous faut un parquet
qui centralise les poursuites et pas des
parquets qui additionnent leurs efforts
avec toute la perte de temps les
différences de l'oise a
peut-être un jour orange le plaisir de
vous parler de salomon la sorte la dea
des difficultés extrêmes parce que la
souveraineté parce que
défiance à l'égard des juges ou plutôt
des parquetiers d'un autre pays si forte
en angleterre font que on perd de vue
cette évidence la grande criminalité
organisée en europe c'est une
criminalité transeuropéennes d'état à
état et la lutte doit être très
européenne surtout quand il s'agit de la
prostitution donc la priorité elle est
là c'est la lutte contre la mafia alors
s'agissant de ça quand vous pensez à ça
vous posez la question qui pour moi
essentielle est-ce que dans la lutte
contre le proxénétisme
organisé contre ces mafias de traite
d'êtres humains ce projet apporte
quelque chose est ce que il est utile à
ce qu'est la vraie cible pas la cible
idéologique pour satisfaire des
postulats de principe sur la violence
quotidienne faite aux femmes même si là
il ya encore beaucoup à faire mais sur
l'essentiel les réseaux le proxénétisme
organisé et je vous réponds non je vous
réponds non
pourquoi parce que la pénalisation du
lian et les nuls en ce qui concerne la
répression entre les réseaux pour une
raison d'évidence constante c'est que le
client ne connaît pas les réseaux
mafieux qui ont apporté la finca n'est
que la fille est d'ailleurs à cet égard
une discrétion absolue une sorte de mur
de silence règne il n'y a pas intérêt à
le connaître et elle n'a encore moins
d'intérêt lui faire connaître donc
interpellé le client dans le la lutte
contre le proxénétisme organisé mafieux
ces mules et c'est plus que nulle
c'est préjudiciable
nul j'ai indiqué pourquoi parce que il
ne sait pas il affinera pas mais parce
que le résultat inévitable
de la pénalisation du client c'est la
clandestinité aussitôt de la
prostitution bien sûr elle va quitter la
rue puisque c'est dans la rue que le
client peut être où va être interpellé
et elle va se réfugier son leica les
pires lieu qui soit on pense
inévitablement
la au parking désert
j'ai pas faire la liste des floréales et
boosket et puis les hôtels et puis
surtout
les studios pour pouvoir continuer à
exercer la prostitution c'est
personne qui l'exercent
garçons aussi peu importe il leur faut
un lieu
le client
par téléphone il ira dans le lieu requis
mais pour fournir les lieux c'est le
réseau qui va le faire lui est à même de
voir des hôtels de pouvoir louer des
studios qui sont indispensables pour que
la prostitution se poursuivait le
résultat c'est que la prise l'ont prise
sur les prostituées devient plus forte
encore parce que le réseau détient les
moyens pour elle de continuer qui sont
en plus exiger donc on renforce la prix
sur la prostitution loin de permettre de
la combattre est évidemment contrepartie
nécessaire les frais généraux étant plus
élevé le prélèvement fait sur les liens
de la fille ou du prostituées seront
plus important donc on arrive cette
conséquence et je crois je disais on se
trompe de cible au lieu de viser les
mafias on vise les clients les clients
ne sert à rien pour identifier les
mafieux et en plus là l'emprise du
réseau mafieux sur le prostitué se fait
plus forte encore j'ajoute alors qu'est
ce qui reste qu'est ce qui reste qui va
être accessible à recherches policières
c'est quoi c'est la prostitution sous sa
forme la plus misérable
c'est à dire la lisière de la forêt
comme on le voit est à dire le parking
désert l'arrière du camion enfin tu t'es
les lieux les plus sordides pour
consommer l'acte dans la clandestinité
ici dans la clandestinité gay s'il n'y a
pas de clients
est la conséquence qui me paraît mais
complètement perdus de vue et qui
révolte les associations de défense des
prostituées c'est les conditions
d'hygiène 20 mois
il faut d'abord penser à ça je vais
d'abord penser à la sécurité
et la sécurité sanitaire des prostituées
c'est pas dans les fourrés les bois et
les arrières des camions désaffectée que
les avoir le minimum d'hygiène possible
vous fait redescendre la prostitution de
rue au niveau le plus bas et ça ça
bouleverse littéralement les
associations vous entendrez sûrement et
moi j'ai été frappé mais frappé de voir
jusqu'où peut aller la conviction
idéologique face à la réalité quand
élu dans un site très nombreux rapports
qui nous remettrait qu' il y a eu en
suède un refus de maintenir de la part
de certaines autorités locales
la distribution gratuite de préservatifs
aux prostituées alors dix ans le client
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas le recevoir
cet interdit vous n'êtes pas
poursuivables mais il ne s'agit pas non
plus de continuer nous n'allons pas vous
aider à cela c'est fini au regard de ce
qu'est la gueule problème sanitaire
quant à une double versées et se dire
mais où sommes-nous dans quel monde
idéologies sommes-nous tombés pour en
arriver là alors que c'est la première
défense des êtres humains alors je
continue
il reste s'agissant de l'inutilité un
argument ne tirèrent par l'argument une
évidence tiré de l'histoire
le fond de l'argumentation et je n'ai
entendu moi de mes oreilles
certains responsables
c'est c'est très simple la prostitution
est un mal plus de clients de
prostituées plus de prostitution
cqfd la pénalisation du client ça fait
disparaître par voie indirecte
le la prostitution tout entière puisque
les prostituées non plus criant donc
elle se prostitue plus
franchement je laisse de côté les
expériences historiques bien connu sur
la suppression la constitution y compris
dans le domaine international
je rappelle c'était des exemples récents
besoin de remonter à saint louis
qui en effet avait interdit pour des
raisons évidemment religieuse la
prostitution à paris oui alors quoi
celle ci s'est transportée immédiatement
en dehors de l'enceinte des forteresses
de l'époque et s'y réfugier dans ce
qu'on a appelé les bourdes au quai sur
les ancêtres des bordels et qu'ils
étaient des cabanes en bois qu'on
reconstruisait le long des remparts
c'est dire que c'est ainsi mais ce que
je marquais c'est quand même regarder
l'histoire et l'histoire la plus récente
est ce que jamais jamais la sanction la
pire qui puisse être infligé un rapport
d'un homme avec une prostituée ouah
prostituées mais je prends exprès une
prostituée basque historiquement c'est
là loin la pire il à risque c'est quoi
mais c'est la maladie vénérienne
s'il ya eu un facteur de dissuasion
constante dans l'histoire
et l'humilité c'est la peur en ayant des
relations avec une prostituée
d'attraper des maladies vénériennes et
je rappelle que ce sont des maladies
extraordinairement grave qui non
seulement affecte l'individu pendant
longtemps mais avec la syphilis le
menait à la morge besoin de citer ici
des esprits avertis après tout
baudelaire on sait de quoi il est mort
le sait tous
bien d'autres écrivains comme lui même
flaubert
maupassant
la peur de le taper la diva derrière les
dissuader d'aller le bordel quand il
était en egypte ou tout simplement à
rouen jamais
jamais
donc la peur ici de la maladie de la
mort qui est la conséquence directe
du rapport avec la prostituée n'a jamais
pu dissuader les clients et j'ai pas
besoin de rappeler ce qu'il en est du
sida parce que si là où cette espèce de
approche simplifiée du problème de la
sexualité
rémunérés mais elle ne prend pas en
compte les vertiges et les abîmes de la
nature humaine parce que c'est ça le
rapport entre le sexe et la mort
valeur cet égard de les évoquer ma on
croirait que freud n'a pas existé on
croirait que le vertige sexe mort ça
n'en porte pas les êtres humains et
c'est oublié ce qu'est la pulsion
sexuelle et surtout la pulsion sexuelle
chez les jeunes gens ça n'a jamais
empêché
sa dissuader certains mais ça n'a jamais
empêché beaucoup d'aller au bordel y
compris les pires et aujourd'hui encore
éviter
regardez ce qui se passe sida
depuis qu'on considère que le sida n'est
pas absolument mortels on sait les
recherches policières ce que vous
entendrez voulions que dans les
backrooms ont alors commencé sans
préservatif ce kit vraiment joué à la
roulette russe
non on continue et on croit qu'une peine
d'un travail d'intérêt général ou un
stage cilic la dissuader les clients
réécoutez alors par proton gerbe à la
solution c'est perpétuité pour ceux qui
iront aux filles comme on disait 60 ans
de sa non c'est simplement pour montrer
que vous êtes là dans un domaine qui est
le plus complexe qui soit et qu'on ne
peut pas y aller rider vue
gic il faut prendre en compte tout ce
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure et surtout
le jeu mais permettre ne jamais
permettre le mal organisé la procession
réaliser le réseau mafieux là il faut
absolument mobiliser toutes les forces
mais la voie choisie n'est pas n'est pas
la bonne elle n'est pas alors je
poursuis en dix ans elle est de surcroît
et on va pas le dire ni l'admettre elle
est porteuse injustice sociale cette loi
parce que qui at-elle frappé elle vint
frapper les clients des palaces
les émirs les oligarques les
consommateurs de cow-girls 1000 $
l'heure
franchement il ya quelqu'un qui croit
sérieusement ça que ce super plutôt ce
tourisme de super luxe
il ne sera pas se poursuivre et se
prémunir avec tous les réseaux condamne
me râble naïveté mais c'est pas ainsi
que les choses se passeront c'est pas
ainsi que les choses se passeront parce
que ce qui restera accessible
à leurs recherches policières et notre
niveau de contraventions cela signifie
comme restrictions pour les possibilités
d'action je dirais contraintes
immédiates
heureusement qu est ce qui va se passer
c'est que resteront en définitive soumis
à 7 mois et s pénalité qui
les clients les plus misérables des plus
misérables des prostituées
c'est à dire sur la voie publique série
enfin ceux qui trouveront là d'être à
l'estivé en des pauvres vivent nus
digère vraiment des pauvres vivent du
ligier et cetera
qui elle par nécessité continuent ils y
seront les seuls accessibles et ainsi
vous aurez l'immunité et les escort girl
de luxe pour les uns et pour les autres
vous aurez la misère constitutionnel
plus la poursuite pénale je peux pas
dire que je considère que ce soit à cet
égard un progrès
moral ni sanitaires reste aussi une
question c'est que ce sera d'autant plus
le cas que je le disais
inévitablement on l'a vu en suède et en
norvège puis c'est un phénomène constant
si vous interdisez la prostitution
devient clandestine si vous interdisez
l'alcool on sait ce qu'a donné la
prohibition aux états unis vous
interdisez la drogue le trafic ne serait
pas dans les pharmacies dans ces camps
la
certitude c'est que ça continuera de
façon autres en dessine mais celles qui
resteront seront celles qui précisément
seront le plus accessible acquis
à la poursuite policière si vous êtes
une attraction il faut poursuivre ceux
qui méconnaissent la loi et faire du
chiffre puisque ça fait partie des
efforts de la police cela se fera
infiniment plus aisément pour ces
malheureuses de la rue et genre j'ai
évoqué leurs clients que ça ne se fera
comme gelée indique et ailleurs donc
vous avez là un problème policiers et
j'attire votre attention aussi pour
traquer les clients il faut des
policiers
pendant ce temps là
savez vous combien nous avons deux
policiers disponibles aujourd'hui
pour lutter contre le mal que j'évoquais
la traite pour lutter contre les mafias
de proxénètes et bien je le sais par
autorités officielles j'ai demandé à
paris la brigade chargée de la
répression de la traite des êtres
humains compte une trentaine de
policiers c'est là dessus que vous allez
prendre ces petits noyaux qui lutte
vraiment être beaucoup de passion entre
les réseaux vous allez les envoyer dans
la rue pour suivre les clients faire des
perquisitions dans les hôtels et la
brigade de répression du proxénétisme de
la préfecture de police de paris compte
une cinquantaine
une cinquantaine de policiers pour
l'ensemble de l'agglomération et du
voisinage le rendez compte or on n'a
déjà pas les effectifs et les moyens
suffisants pour lutter contre ces maux
évident majeur
et on ira les prélever sur ses effectifs
là pour les consacrés à la poursuite de
clients dont jaillit seront
recrutés vous pensez que nos concitoyens
en période d'austérité budgétaire
apprécieront le fait qu'on va recruter
des policiers n'ont pas chargés de
protéger leur sécurité leur personne
lors bien c'est tout à fait légitime
mais d'aller poursuivre les clients qui
vont l'a acceptée les citations des
filles ou des garçons alors alors c'est
une question que vous devez examiner
celle des moyens et je crois pour ma
part profondément que vous devez
entendre ce point le directeur de la
police judiciaire sinon maïs de
l'intérieur comme vous devez entendre la
garde des sceaux pour savoir si à
effectif constant alors là j'en parle en
connaissance de cause elle aussi à
effectif constant le parquet se réjouira
où sera disposé circulaire à l'appui à
faire à conduire les poursuites dans ce
domaine où elle est contrôlée
c'était encore une charge de plus pour
un ministère public jeudi ce concert
d'autres secteurs qui n'en peut plus des
infractions répétitives et qui considère
lui-même à juste titre comme maintenant
pas véritablement des attaques majeures
à l'ordre public et des formes ça me
voyais autant la mobilisation et de la
police et la justice et la reprise est
disponible et volontaire quand il s'agit
des mafias autant aller traquer clients
vous verrez le sentiment et la
disponibilité en sommes en moyens jeudi
en résolution alors j'en arrive à fin
juillet là je dis avec beaucoup de
fermeté
la loi proposée mi koné
méconnaît la jurisprudence de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme dans ce
domaine et méconnaît par conséquent les
principes de la convention européenne
des droits qui je le rappelle sont la
structure morale et juridique de notre
système judiciaire
aurais je dis ça parce que je vous
demande de vous référer aux décisions de
principe de la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme dans ce domaine dont
je connais bien cette jurisprudence
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
je rappelle que la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme ce n'est pas seulement
à usage des états de l'union européenne
ça vaut pour les 47 états du conseil de
l'europe ça vaut pour tous les états
européens y compris ceux qui se trouvent
à l'est de l'europe et sont pas membres
de l'union alors s'agissant des
pratiques sexuelles la cour dans un
arrêt qui ressemblait assez récent du 17
février 2005 cas à et à des yaks les
initiales parce que c'est une décision à
propos de pratiques sexuelles absolument
effrayante l'effrayante ces deux oiseaux
mais vraiment effrayante rendu ça ne
s'est pas des rapports prostitutionnel
cet événement à propos de ses relations
sadomasochistes la cour a précisé sa
position
le droit
d'entretenir des relations sexuelles
découle du droit fondamental de disposer
de son corps nous parlons de majeur le
droit de disposer de son corps partie
intégrante de la notion d'autonomie
personnelle préserver celle considérant
83 et cours a ajouté
la notion d'autonomie personnelle peut
s'entendre au sens du droit d'opérer des
choix concernant son propre corps celui
en termes encore plus simple et clair le
droit pénal n'a pas à intervenir dans le
domaine des pratiques sexuelles entre
adultes consentants
ça ne le regarde pas les adultes
consentants sont maîtres de leur corps
leur sexualité et celle qu'ils veulent
pratiquer du moment qu'il n'ya pas
contrainte
libre à eux de le faire
c'est un des éléments profond de la
liberté individuelle et je le rappel du
droit au respect de l'intimité une nuit
pébé qui par ailleurs a aussi menacé en
ce moment mais c'est une constante alors
dans les seuls cas où on doit intervenir
j serment et finalement la cour disent
et ce pour des raisons particulièrement
grave et c'est le cas en l'espèce on
l'avait été le marquis de sade était
très déplacée jusqu'à des mutilations
qui ont effrayant dans les orgies brive
effrayante alors ici
c'est seulement dans ce cas là que on
perd mais l'ingérence des pouvoirs
publics mais la cour européenne l'homme
a analysé le statut de la prostitution
en france dans un arrêt qui est un art
est très important souvent cité le 11
septembre 2007 trembler contre france
elle a analysé le problème de la
prostitution
elle a souligné qu' en france
la prostitution n'est ni interdite à la
différence du proxénétisme seront parle
des majeures à la différence du
proxénétisme qui lui est même et la cour
dit la prostitution n'est pas interdite
ni contrôler
les revenus de la prostitution c'est la
cour qu'il relève sont soumis à l'impôt
et aux charges sociales ce qui
d'ailleurs est heureux parce que les
charges sociales implique en
contrepartie le recours sanitaire si
important à des processions streit notre
un des
terminaux dans la prostitution des
adultes est donc légale en france ce
n'est pas une pratique illégale la loi
le reconnaît elle est admise mais et
c'est là le coeur de ce que je veux vous
dire la cour dont le considérant 25 à
souligner c'est des termes très forts et
c'est rare sous sa plume
que
la prostitution en général est
incompatible avec la dignité de la
personne humaine ce que moi je crois
mais elle n'est incompatible en termes
juridiques
que l'or ce qu'elle est contrainte je
relis la prostitution est incompatible
avec la dignité de la personne humaine
dès lors qu'elle est contrainte on peut
pas s'arrêter
dans cette phrase au premier membre de
la phrase la prostitution est contraire
à la dignité humaine parce que endroits
et notamment et surtout en droit pénal
encore faut-il qu'elle soit contrainte
la personne à ses relations
institutionnelles
car on ne peut pas avoir la liberté à la
fois et en même temps l'interdiction
l'interdiction apparaît quand kantien la
contrainte quand il n'y a plus d'
acceptation que le consentement si
volatilisé sous la pression ou la
contrainte distale alors à ce moment là
vous êtes dans une situation où il
convient d'intervenir et réfléchie sosie
qui contraint à se prostituer
le proxénète les réseaux c'est pas le
désir d'une robe qui peut être considéré
comme la contrainte c'est exactement la
pression exercée et estime par le tiers
et c'est ce qu'on a évoqué la présidente
de taz secret des familles ça c'est la
contrainte et
c'est la notion de traitements inhumains
et dégradants qui si importante celle de
l'article 3 de la convention elle le
trouve sa place qu'à la condition selon
la cour que ce soit une prostitution
contrainte sinon c'est la disposition
par chacun chaque adulte la disposition
libre de son corps quel que soit le
sentiment moral ou le jugement moral que
nous portions sur ses comportements
c'est ainsi dans les sociétés de liberté
c'est le droit à disposer de son corps
et le droit
à l'intimité de la vie allait alors se
pose une question et cette question ne
se pose directement regard du projet
si
il est nécessaire
que la contrainte soit exercée sur le ou
la prostituée
question la preuve de la contrainte et
cette preuve de la contrainte elle est
dans le système suédois
tout simplement escamoté dans le projet
aussi propositions aussi s capoter
comment
parle à ce que j'avais évoqué la
troisième postulat marquer aucune femme
ne pose prostituées s'il n'y est pas
contrainte c'est comme ça on peut
regarder proposition du net on peut
regarder l'expérience multi séculaire
mais la femme pour
ça existe il ya d'autres raisons que la
contrainte pour lesquelles on se livre à
la prostitution
mais là la charge de la preuve de la
contrainte elle est escamoté puisque
c'est le fait de la prostitution qui en
lui-même prouve la contrainte tout ce
logis c'est fini elle se prostitue donc
elle est contrainte puisqu'elle ne se
prostitueraient pas si elle n'était pas
contrainte cqfd c'est fini l'escapade
non ça c'est pas possible on va jouer
avec des questions aussi fondamentales
que la preuve à charge de l'accusation
et dire le fait lui-même suffit à
établir l'innocence pas possible ici la
publicité c'est possible il faut c'est
ça dépasse le cadre du débat sur la
pénalisation des clients il faut
toujours respecter les fondements mêmes
de ce qu'ils sont dans liberté
judiciaire c'est quand même l'essentiel
c'est la charge de la preuve cette à
l'accusation
la présomption d'innocence c'est à celui
qui est poursuivi ça vaut dans le
domaine sexuel comme dans les autres
c'est toujours à l'accusation de prouver
la culpabilité
c'est toujours à la défense de pouvoir
exercer loi ici la charge de la preuve
elle implique que c'est le ministère
public qui doit rapporter la preuve de
la contrainte pas le simple fait qu elle
est prostituée les contraintes donc je
poursuis de clients appartenant il faut
dans à propos de cette personne là et à
ce moment là cette période là on puisse
prouver que il s'exerce sur elle une
contrainte il va se dire c'est probable
il ya une exigence de preuve qui est ici
comme toujours et sans ciel parce que
c'est en définitive la seule protection
contre les accusations la charge de la
preuve je ne faut pas vivre dans un
univers et resnik moi je peux vous
indiquer
le professionnel il ya bien longtemps
qui se souvient
qu'avec des textes comme ça il aima fia
le chantage ça l'a donnée alors là je
peux vous en répondre parce que je les
ai vus s'exercer au moment où existait
encore la prostituée le délit le délit
d'homosexualité en france aux sexualités
poursuivi c'était l'homosexualité entre
l'adulte et l'adolescent afin que jeunes
de 15-18 ans
il y avait des réseaux qui travaillait
très bien là dessus car l'accusation
d'être un euro sexuelles et des rapports
avec un jeune homme c'était la mort
sociale pour celui qui en était le jeu
n'est pas m'en la mort sociale pas
seulement au niveau le plus élevé des
responsabilités politiques je suis là
c'est d'ailleurs l'exemple mais tout
court partout et bien le jouer la
pratique était la suivante on retrouve
ça d'ailleurs droit sartre dans les
chemins de la liberté
le gîte on
a collé ou se laissèrent accolé par le
riche homosexuels dans sa maturité
et puis rennes un champ de tel est l ce
moment là faisait irruption qui le reste
de la bande
et ont commencé un chantage qui ne
s'arrêtait plus
s'arrêter plus et qui conduisait
vraiment je peux le dire certains hommes
au désespoir ce que l'idée que ça sache
dans leur milieu leur entourage leur
famille leurs enfants qu'ils avaient des
rapports avec digitaux professionnels
c'était tout simplement la destruction
sociale mais là un trop facile rendez
vous est pris si dans le réseau mais les
quatre salles et les voitures tout le
mois de la porte de l'hôtel beau c'est
qu'il ira à telle heure photo photo qui
ensuite vont relever le numéro de la
voiture ou chez tous gracia l'intérieur
et vous n'avez plus qu'à venir présenter
la note puisque c'est une infraction
puisque ce sera une poursuite pénale
puisque la conséquence sera une sanction
qui figurera au conte
au casier judiciaire
les effets pervers des lois existent
aussi pour ceux qui savent et cette
catégorie de criminels savait manier et
c'est papa l'a retenu morale qui jouera
donc voila voila on retente on l'a
abandonne le dire un fort des principes
ce à quoi on aboutira j'ai terminé en
disant il ya aussi je suis je puis dire
minimes 1 le noyau dur des principes du
droit pénal français
en droit pénal vous avez l'auteur de
l'infraction et vous avez le complice
qui est complice
celui qui provoque celui qui par
province un site à la commission de
l'infraction il est complice c'est dans
le code pénal et c'est un principe qui
ne remonte pas à hier et ce à la théorie
de la complicité ici
l'art il à cette situation mais qui
défilent intelligence juridique la
raison juridique
le provocateur ou la provocatrice disons
c'est plus communément le cas
elle propose
peut-être d'ailleurs très jolie
café
son regard appuyé et cetera des charmes
évidents
c'est là la tentation
bien heureux
au paradis dans ligne directe celui qui
n'a jamais connu la tentation mais on
arrive à ce résultat
celle qui a proposé
qui sait où il veut aller tiens à
conserver sa partie du contrat est pas
poursuivables mais l'autre
dont la ferme volonté le caractère
un principe de ville les entation ce
jour là les abandonner cette maîtrise de
l'huile a cédé à la tentation
je vais en référer un film récent jeune
et jolie je me dis je vais faire et
cetera l'on connaît tous
lui c'est la poursuite pénale la
condamnation à une peine faibli au stage
qui sera d'ailleurs singulier
pour ceux qui seront mais ne sait pas
que ça et les travaux d'intérêt général
et le travail d'intérêt général il se
fait dans un lieu que généralement
associatifs publics et on saura pourquoi
il est là parce que c'est fou ce que
comme indiscrétions ce domaine
lui donc aura sa peine ce sera au casier
judiciaire je la dis pas pour longtemps
et c'est y sera et bizarrement les
sommiers judiciaire ne se dit pas si
aisément on croit alors pense
à des jeunes gens un soir de concours
réussi comme jadis à 10 élèves service
militaire ou un match de football
triomphant
peu trop de bière il cède à la tentation
à ce que ça donnera le moment ils sont
en concurrence pour devenir ingénieur en
chef de laisser cf
ça reste
alors est ce que véritablement
on peut considérer que c'est avec cette
loi là qu'on va éradiquer ce mal certain
que la prostitution est ce que c'est une
loi que nous devons inscrire la dans
notre arsenal législatif
certain nombre certainement pas
j'ajoute que ja mais
l'obligation de réserve joue il meurt et
c'est l'aspect que je retiendrai pour
conclure
il demeure
que
quand
on regarde ce texte
ce qui n'est en question c'est la
liberté des êtres humains de disposer de
leur corps
l'adul enfin le droit de disposer de son
corps le fco jadis faisaient des cours
où il évoquait la police décor la
tentation ultime des régimes
totalitaires qui ne suffit pas de
discipline et les visas encore faut-il
disciples et les corps et pour finir les
âmes et la discipline des corps ça mais
là l'expression ça vous pouvez ça ne
paie pas je vous interdis dans votre
quête avoue adultes du plaisir avec un
autre adulte ruinerait je le veux bien
mais pourquoi pas si l'autre côté choisi
cette compensation là où cette
contrepartie là c'est aussi ces libertés
et là je vous l'interdît
interdit parce que par définition
vous avait contraint les femmes à se
prostituer et dans ces conditions c'est
vous qui paierez c'est vous qui serez pu
laisser par contre je veux pas entrer
dans les querelles qu'on connaît dans ce
domaine ce que je dis simplement c'est
au regard de la liberté de la liberté
élémentaire de disposer de son corps
dans la vie privée dans l'intimité de la
vie privée si menacée aujourd'hui dans
l'intimité de la vie privée
pourvu que ce soit sans contrainte sans
violence car avec insupportable et à mes
yeux sont actuels mais souvent criminels
mais s'il n'y a pas de contrainte s'ils
sont des motivations quelle qu'elle soit
que ce soit l'ambition les coudes bible
et cupidité ou que ce soit l'argent
peu importe où les irsc il serait
beaucoup mieux où le plaisir parce que
c'est pas absolument interdit
en tout cas dans le code pénal
ça regarde chacun des êtres humains
adultes ce qui doit être l'objet de
notre unique et rentiers pas unique mais
première préoccupation
je le répète ce sera ma conclusion pas
se divertir toujours viser ces révisions
mafieux qui sont des criminels il ne pas
transformer au code pénal en affichage
d'idéologie
merci beaucoup c'est badinter g nous
sommes contraints par le temps donc je
vais je vais donner la parole aux
collègues qui souhaitent poser des
questions juste un petit mouton dans vos
propos j'ai noté les collègues qui
étaient la semaine passée ont dû le
noter également sur votre souhait de la
lutte contre les réseaux de traite je
pense qu'on ne peut que partager c'est
tout un avis que le président de la
commission spéciale partage pleinement
et ça nous ramène aux propos que tenait
la semaine passée le procureur national
antimafia italien qui appelait de ses
voeux qu'il y ait effectivement un
parquet européen et qu'elle ait une
politique européenne de lutte contre eux
ne le connaît donc maintenant avec la
nouvelle commission alors là on change
comme le 30 sujet visite plus hautes et
les plus importants en tout cas
j'espère j'espère que
après les élections européennes n'ont
pas un parc européen pour l'ensemble des
28 et en aura pas lorsque lors
d'angleterre m'a dis jamais
jamais ça vous le mettez pas dans le
procès verbal ça concerne un autre sujet
mais jamais le dis jamais jamais les
citoyens anglais ne mettront que
l'action publique à partir d'un pays
étranger viendra frapper un citoyen
britannique
après tout la société anglaise reposer
sonore de reposer sur la ps corpus âge
c'est pas pour que ce soit soumis à
d'autres donc pas d'espérance mais une
coopération renforcée qui est prévu
d'ailleurs qui est prévue au texte du
traité on passera d'euros juste à ce
qu'ils aient un parquet européen ça oui
et ça j'espère qu'après après l'élection
de la nouvelle commission on voit si
attachés parce que c'est nécessaire dans
ce domaine là
beaucoup d'autres si la drogue tout la
corruption alors madame michelle meyer
apporter un malade masson maire et après
c'est samarrai après forno
pour la clarté de vos propos
des propos que je ne partage pas
fondamentalement parce que je suis de
celles et de ceux qui pensent que la
prostitution n'a pas changé ce sont les
formes de prostitution qui ont changé
mais que fondamentalement le fait
d'acheter un acte sexuel est bien ancrée
dès le départ dans cette forme dans ce
qu'est la prostitution alors et là ce
dans tout ce que j'avais dit j'aurais
j'ai pas le temps j'aurais aimé creuser
ce que vous appelez consentement est
contrainte ça ça mérite vraiment un
débat est ce qu'il y aurait
ce mal profond qui concernerait les
réseaux ce que vous ce que vous dites
est ce qu'on entend on souvent aussi
dense personnes qui viennent auditionné
et puis une autre forme plus acceptable
de prostitution pour ma part je ne le
pense pas alors j'ai un sentiment mais
je ne veux pas penser venant de vous
monsieur le ministre c'est que j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il y aurait presque une
fatalité
voir ce que je ne souhaite pas une
résignation à ce phénomène de
prostitution
et que les moyens ne serait jamais
suffisant que ces leviers de répression
d'éducation aussi parce que c'est quand
même un volet dans lequel cette
proposition de loi
entend agir
comment est ce que on peut sortir de là
et se dire que demain ce qu'on espère
pour nos enfants nos petits-enfants et
bien il n'y est pas ce que l'on constate
aujourd'hui une forme insupportable de
bon nombre de femmes et d'hommes qui
sont
envoyées en tout cas qui ont recours à
la prostitution ça ne peut pas pour moi
dans la société que je souhaite
être des bornes comme ça faisant partie
du paysage alors où peut-on trouver de
l'espoir l'espérance est ce que ces
messages d'éducation qu'on veut porter
autour de l'égalité entre les filles et
les garçons entre les hommes et les
femmes qu'est ce que ça peut avoir comme
impact si on dit la prostitution et elle
fait partie de la réalité en france et
par
les problèmes parce que voilà cette
sélection vous faites une à plusieurs
la question égalité hommes femmes
ne jouent pas ici du tout dans ma pensée
est pour une raison simple c'est que je
crois que le mouvement actuel va se
poursuivre il y aura deux
proportionnellement de plus en plus
devra se situer sommes par rapport au
nombre global de prostituées
précisément pour des raisons qu'on
connaît des évolutions de la société
et en ma part l'égalité entre zobo les
hétéros cite aussi un impératif
catégorique donc on assistera à ça mais
indépendamment de cette considération là
je vous réponds vous disant
là le droit le droit
de disposer de choisir de disposer de
mon corps à des fins prostitutionnel
c'est ce que la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme au lit scellier
scellier à d'un choix individuel
sauf contrainte ici il ya des hommes et
des femmes qui préfèrent soulever tarn
ne pas aller chercher du travail aux usa
c'est un travail dans les conditions
désolante et pour un salaire de misère
accusé la société mais on peut pas dire
que du coup le client d'un malfaiteur
vous comprenez vous pouvez choisir très
bien mon la jce c'est une heure après
choisi en un mois nous apprend hibon la
prostitution arguments plus évoqué
l'exclusion vous évoquez vous l'avez
dans un certain nombre de pays il ya des
pays interdisent constitution puisque la
prostitution elle mal nous l'interdisent
on le nomme m c'est que nulle part
jamais ça va fonctionner si je prends
les exemples les plus récents
c'est à dire ceux des états socialiste
afin d'y socialiste et un communiste
lorsque existait les régimes
totalitaires de jadis dans toute leur
force on m'interdisait même est arrivé
les râles et je suis allé à moscou je
suis allé à varsovie j'ai connu ces
sociétés je les ai vus servir leur
poussoir mais je les ai vus il y avait
des prostituées la prostitution était
interdite pénalement sanctionnée pour
tout le monde pour tout le monde c'est à
dire celui qui s'y adonnent le client
celles qui s'y livrent la prostituée et
c'est le proxy
si c'est ça le choix que vous proposez
moi je dis seulement historiquement
c'est plus lourde des as qu'autre chose
c'est une un système qui ne jamais
jamais jamais jamais était observé la
prostate la prohibition de la
prostitution j'ai essayé d'évoquer les
raisons la pulsion sexuelle c'est ce que
voudrait qu'ils font que des hommes
risquent la mort la mort pour satisfaire
une pulsion sexuelle et vous me dites ah
mais non c'est l'être humain il est l
être humain il est comme ça il a des
pulsions sexuelles
et on va pas dire la fin du 21e siècle
comme les ignore comme le père du boulou
à la fin du 19e on sait
très bien on choisit face à cette
situation en fonction un de principe j
attachent une extrême importance j'ai
dit à mes yeux c'était en effet un mal
social mais baladi aussi est un mal
social je vous dis simplement si la
prohibition est un choix mais c'est
aussi absurde que de dire quand il
s'agit du rapport la prostitution le
friant je les dis
le dealer peut proposer son poison
le dealer celui qui l'offre peut vous
proposer votre dose
votre ecstasy votre cannabis à vous
dites
c'est le fournisseur
ne poursuit pas celui qui accepte on
poursuit
si vous n'avez pas la contrainte c'est
un choix moral de la part de celui ou de
celle qu'ils exercent la prostitution
vous voyez je vous interdis ce choix
moral pour pouvez pas vous devez pas
je ne pas la position que je prends
parce que je sais que 1 c'est en effet
dans les faits dans la réalité humaine
impossible impossible à faire observer
et deux parce que ça crée tous les maux
secondaire que j'ai évoqués nous ne
faisons pas une législation pour des
anges
et les meilleures intentions et dieu
sait que j'en ai vues elles aboutissent
aussi à paver l'enfer des textes
juridiques
là vous êtes dans les zones noires de
l'espèce humaine
c'est comme ça
alors me dire c'est la faute des hommes
parce que placer exactement sa masse ou
tire ici ne paraît insupportable s'est
fait faire cette espèce de choix de
cible on dit constitution interdite
contraire nous l'estimons valeurs de
notre société
réponse pour les droits de l'homme vous
avez le droit de disposer de votre corps
vous êtes adulte c'est l'intimité de
votre vie privée vous en faites ce que
vous voulez y compris
y compris pour des mobiles qui sont
aussi bien le désir
est là d'abord l'amour le désir à
fassions
je sais quelle autre pratique où la
cupidité ou l'ambition ou l'ambition
indépendamment de l'argent dans tout ça
c'est qu'istres mal
je préfère la jurisprudence de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme à
laquelle nous sommes soumis chacun est
maître de son corps pourvu qu'ils soient
adultes au respect de la vie privée
l'intimité de la vie privée et la
condition qu'il n'y soit pas contrat et
j'en reviens toujours à ça pas parce que
c'est la contrainte mais parce que c'est
la mafia les mafias qui exercent leurs
contraintes évoquant gibier au départ
poursuit on poursuit on vise une cible
qui n'est pas la bonne parce que ça ne
permettra en rien ce qui concerne le
tour pour la mafia rien mais le
contraire est évident alors bon et ben
oui la vision du monde pas tellement
optimiste
j'ai eu l'occasion dans ma longue vie de
jésus avec
contrairement à ce que croient re-so
l'homme n'est pas bon je préfère
montesquieu de bonnes institutions et
éducation comme dirait condorcet peuvent
légèrement dans le meilleur des cas
trempé ce qu'il ya de mauvais
fondamentalement dans la nature humaine
est là en dehors d'enregistrement de dia
j'avais l'habitude de me suis moi mes
enfants étaient en âge et laissant les
dires toujours l'homme est mauvais il me
tournant vers ma fille
que j'ai une passion de perdre 6 et
surtout le jeune homme appelle soit sa
fuite bah je crois n'est pas bon la
femme non plus d'ailleurs l'être humain
du pas bon ainsi mais tel qu'il est tel
que nous nous voulons une société de
liberté je m'en tiens à la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme vous
pouvez faire votre choix je le dis au
départ moi je respecte je sais que ce
sont des préoccupations d'ordre c'est
pas des ambitions d'un c'est pas des
calculs cd je comprendre qu'on déteste
la prostitution c'est mon cas aussi mais
c'est pas la question c'est le problème
social c'est les bonnes et les mauvaises
lois et cette loi telle qu'elle est
c'est une mauvaise droit qu'on vous
propose un sérésien le deviendra
erard joindre aux cimetières sous la
lune des textes est inutile ou pignan
croyez moi un grand nombre de loi votée
j'aurai fait oublier de passer la
présidence et rapporteur parce que je
suis attendu dans peu de temps aux
séances et
en temps de jeu et inscrit un
collègue qui souhaitent poser des
questions à madame masson maret d'abord
madame brienz et donc voila merci c'est
le président je pense que si l'on me
donnait 30 secondes vous êtes déjà très
gentil parce que le temps a couru
monsieur le ministre si tu veux adresser
à vous tous deux forment d'abord le
défenseur des droits de l'homme je crois
que vous êtes un symbole et votre
présence aujourd'hui pour nous est
capital dans une loi qu est souvent un
peu ambigu on ne sait pas toujours
quelle position prendre vous avez été
très clair en tant que défenseur des
droits de l'homme vous avez fait appel
vous avez parlé de michel foucault jeu
si vous avez un tableau de michel
foucault dans votre bureau c'est vrai
bien connu et c'était vraiment quelqu'un
qui s'est battu contre la police des
corps donc c'est très important d'avoir
de citer cette personne vous avez
également cité très rapidement
les sources de cette loi avec le
positionnement des féministes
américaines avec la loi sur les genres
etc je vous parlerai évidemment de
margaret me de karen ornées de runes
benedictus et féministe américain
exactement mais peut-être que cette loi
est passée pour madame va peut-être que
cette loi est en train de dévier une
pensée féministe et samassa m'inquiète
énormément maintenant je vais vous poser
quatre questions en tant que juriste
vous n'aurez pas temps de me répondre
mais peut-être que dans la mobilité de
réponse finalement par écrit ou d'une
autre façon ces quatre questions sont
très simples elles sont très claires
comment expliquez vous que cette loi
était votée par l'assemblée nationale au
delà des clivages politiques sans
réflexion vraiment profonde et
finalement de façon presque
confidentiel
je sais vous n'aurez pas temps de
répondre mais j'aimerais avoir une
réponse là dessus
je sais comment comment excuser moi vous
n'avez pas abordé le caractère
migratoires dont vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure parce que dans cette loi il ya
un caractère migratoires qui est très
important c'est laisser les avantages
qu'on m'a donnée à des populations
venant du monde entier qui vont accepter
de se réhabiliter afin qu'ils m'ont
demandé avec carte de séjour et tout le
restant comme avantage que pensez-vous
de l'amendement demandé et qui a été
accepté sur la vulnérabilité
un personnes vulnérables donner aux
prostituées sur ce statut c'est une
chose extrêmement importante à mon avis
est la dernière question c'était tout de
même une question qui m'interpelle parce
que j'ai bien compris votre
positionnement vous êtes contre cette
loi vous l'avais dit au nom des droits
de l'homme et je vous suis absolument
par rapport à cour européenne des droits
de l'homme mais toi même une question
reste en suspens dans les pays
indonésien et autres ou d'une
pénalisation du client par rapport aux
mineurs dans les voyages touristiques
sexuelle at home fait de l'effet donc sa
place en suspens tout de même quelque
part le fait que lorsque l'on pénalise
il y as peut-être un effet je sais
voudrais pas toi me répondre à d'autres
questions s'il reste on pourra voir si
on peut avoir un retour un jour ça
serait très intéressant jeu merci
monsieur je discute avec disposition
c'est la moindre des choses à tous
égards alors répond sur les conditions
vont de la loi ça la pratique
parlementaire montre que tous les bandes
sont pas nécessairement rempli moment du
vote d'une loi je crois que là n'était
pas spécialement j'ajoute le ça a été
des voitures en un temps limité ce n'est
pas la seule loi et on en connaître plus
importantes qui ont été acquises ainsi
conditions-là look ça c'est
essentiellement ce que je souhaite c'est
que dans cette maison et travaux sont
sérieux ne dis pas qu'il ne soit pas
aussi à l'assemblée nationale mais
particulièrement sérieux vous examiniez
tous les aspects de la loi et notamment
j'insiste
écouter ce qu'elle concerne ne parlons
pas surtout pas non vous avez peut-être
déjà fait il faut écouter parce que
c'est à la fois déchirant éloquent il
faut jamais perdre de vue que c'est elle
et eux qui s'adresse d'abord cette loi y
compris s'agissant du problème sanitaire
qui n'est pas le plus mince de ce que
j'ai évoquées par classe est clair en ce
qui concerne la question de la personne
fume g soit à fait d'accord là on
assimile aux mineurs je trouve ça tout à
fait légitime en ce qui concerne le
caractère migratoires j'ai rappelé au
début nous fait bien le rappeler que la
procession d'aujourd'hui c'est une proxy
dans les faits les les déambulatoires
elle se promène n'est que le résultat
est une présence importante d'étrangers
sur le d'étrangères ou d'étrangers sur
le sol français se livrant à la
prostitution par rapport aux
pourcentages de nationaux ça beaucoup
changé depuis 20 ou 30 ans mais surtout
de les dire alors j'attire l'attention
de la commission le rapporteur j'attire
votre attention sur un point il faut
vous regardiez de très près et vous
fassiez venir le directeur des libertés
publiques ou le ministre de l'intérieur
sur la question d'une énorme et m'en
préoccuper
pour pouvoir et c'est bien réinsérer des
prostituées qui veulent quitter la
prostitution
on a prévu des régularisations
je m'interrogeais je me disais dans le
moment nous sommes avec ce qui se passe
en ukraine
la mafia vient pour trois mois bon futur
changera d'abord modèle ses atouts mais
ensuite tu auras une carte de résidence
et une carte de travail est là
c'est une ignominie de plus parce qu'il
sen ils utiliseront les dispositions
d'une loi qui est foncièrement généreux
il faut le rappeler foncièrement
généreuse pourquoi
alors fin ça sera un appel d'air parce
que pour connaître ces pays vous savez
partir avoir le droit de séjour et une
carte de travail c'est le rêve on voit
ce qui se passe au sud à lampedusa voyez
ce que les gens peuvent risquer leur vie
le peu d'argent qu'ils ont pour
simplement arriver alors a fortiori leur
dire ou trois quatre mois vous allez
avoir et donc il faut faire là il faut
vous interrogez les directeurs de jeu
propre vraiment le directeur des
libertés publiques ou le ministre de
l'intérieur parce que c'est une question
très important et dans lequel je fasse
ran un rang pourcel
voilà pour cette audition de robert
badinter l'ancien garde des sceaux et
sénateur socialiste des hauts-de-seine
s'est exprimé devant la commission
spéciale sur la lutte contre le système
prostitutionnel qui examine donc au fond
la proposition de loi socialiste sur ce
sujet vous pouvez toujours voir et
revoir toutes les auditions sur notre
site sur publicsenat.fr prochain rendez
vous de l'actualité parlementaire à 19h
pour 24 heures sénat présenté par notre
fils gérard très bonne fin de journée
sur les chaînes parlementaires